doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
wenn wir als europäer wo wir schon
wissen was in europa haben nämlich den
bin mag die außenpolitik also viele
tolle sachen dass wir versuchen zu
verbessern permanent zu verbessern das
ist mein job hier
wir können wir können fortfahren es tut
mir leid die unterbrechung tut mir leid
wir wollen sie auch nicht zur regel
machen ich bin
wir machen auch schon schlechten
eindruck ich begrüße ganz hat sich das
schweizer fernsehen wenn man einen
schlechten eindruck bei den eidgenossen
und jetzt muss einer eben fahren oder
andere unterwegs mit dem eu abgeordneten
markus pieper also dann auf zum nächsten
termin und der eu abgeordneten inge
gräßle beide konservativ
zurzeit 13 mit der frauen wir brauchen
sie etwa eine stunde länger beruf
die eu für die einen ein
bürokratiemonster für die anderen ein
friedensprojekt aber wie funktioniert
die eu im alltag wird weil es wieder es
ist mein dritter europawahlkampf und
wieder ist es ein wahlkampf bei dem man
sich sehr schwertut das thema europa an
den mann und an die frau an den wählern
die wählerinnen zu bekommen
die europäische union und die euro zone
war am auseinanderbrechen und es ist
eine gigantische leistung sie zusammen
gehalten zu haben sich auch die leistung
von angela merkel wolfgang schäuble
wer sehr auseinander gebrochen muss jede
sagen hätten wir jetzt natürlich eine
ganz andere gefechtslage und
wahrscheinlich werde saal voll weil dann
alle fragen würden wie konntet ihr die
eurozone die europäische union in diesem
zustand lassen warum habt ihr nicht
geholfen
die meisten ausladen autozulassungen das
habe ich auch gehört habe mich auch
gewundert vorbei in den ganzen
krisenländer und natürlich die
autozulassungen zugenommen haben das
finde ich ein gutes zeichen weil ich ja
zeigt dass dort die wende geschafft
wurde als gesetze beschließen
diesen übergestülpt worden danke dass
sie das ansprechen sie haben völlig
recht
und wenn in den letzten jahren fehler
gemacht wurden dann das dass man
versucht hat alles über einen kamm zu
scheren
da schreibt dir vor wie viel salz pro
kilogramm auf 100 gramm in einem
orientalisch sein darf mein vater
beckett seit 60 jahren wenn ich den
frage wie viel salz und nimmt er sagt er
hat handvoll angeblich haben jetzt in
brüssel alle verstanden dass sie so
nicht weitermachen können wir können
leider für das was wir tun nirgendwo
abschreiben wir müssen alles selber
entwickeln und ich würde mich sehr gern
darum kümmern um das dann auch in die
tat umsetzen zu können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
markus pieper auf wald bei unternehmern
der kreis warendorf ist von der
exportquote vor 30 jahren war über 20
prozent heute ist er über 40 prozent
und jedes prozentpunkt bringt im
ihk-bezirk 2000 arbeitsplätze
wenn man über europa immer schimpft über
wirken krümmung und griechenland und ich
weiß nicht aber das ist auch europa ja
aber der kern europas in frieden
freiheit währte und das was hier
stattfindet
das was europa ausmacht das ist die
vorbereitung für unsere kleinen firmen
auf die globalisierung mit den offenen
grenzen mit den einheitlichen
maschinenrichtlinie mit den
einheitlichen umweltvorgaben sie können
plötzlich für größere märkte produzieren
das ist alles nicht mehr so eng also wir
versuchen trotz aller schwierigkeiten
dinge gemeinsam zu machen
europa ist ein einzigartiger
zusammenschluss von 28 staaten es gibt
weltweit ein solches modell nicht diese
friedensidee
dieselbe friedliche lösung von
konflikten die hat sich eigentlich jetzt
wirklich in die indy himmel aller
eingegraben und eingepflanzt
[Musik]
die meisten leute denken ja immer und es
greift um sich so die eu ist ein verein
von profis da sitzen in brüssel ein paar
komplette idioten zusammen die den
ganzen tag sind nur überlegen wie sie
die menschheit schikanieren können also
ich kann allen glaubhaft versichern das
ist nicht so die eu hat schon überlegt
sich schon sehr genau macht übrigens
macht sehr viele dinge aber mit grosser
große rationalität vielleicht manchmal
zu rational wenn ich denke die großen
verdienste der eu harmonisierung von
industrieprodukten also harmonisierung
im vest festschreibung wichtiger
technischer details um so überhaupt auch
nur eine öffnung eine grenzöffnung für
diese produkte und den gemeinsamen markt
herzustellen also die famosen komischen
krummen rücken als haben wir verdient
gehabt wegen der krummen rücken nur muss
sie halt auch mal sagen das sind alles
industrienormen beziehungsweise
handelsnamen die dazu dienen dass diese
verdammte gurken noch in die kiste passt
weil wir haben halt einen gemeinsamen
markt dann muss ich in griechenland wenn
ich einsatzgruppen bestelle muss man
sich genau darauf verlassen können was
der wieder aussieht was der form hat und
außerdem aus transport gründen hat man
hat dann die industrie ihren festgelegt
wie viele gruppen dann in so eine kiste
passen wegen der permanenten kritik hat
die eu die krumme gurke wieder
abgeschafft und was ist jetzt jetzt
pastior gehalt nicht mehr in die kiste
oder aber interessanterweise haben sich
die normen praktisch aufrecht erhalten
obwohl sie nicht mehr festgeschrieben
sind aber die industrie und auch der
gartenbau verhält sich weiter so als ob
es diese norm immer noch gibt
die situation ist im moment so dass man
mich ständig gar nicht mehr benennen
darf mit hinweis darauf dass sonst die
anti europäer gestärkt werden und der
effekt wird genau die stark und der anti
europäer sein weil natürlich das nicht
benennen von missständen dazu führt dass
man diese missstände dann auch nicht
mehr verändert das ist das interesse des
apparats und deswegen kann ich nur sagen
wird auf dem schlecht zu reden wir
brauchen leute die sie verändern
in die richtige richtung veränderung
[Musik]
ja dass es die überhaupt gibt dass sie
zusammenhält dass alle zusammenarbeiten
und dass sie alle zusammen um
politikfelder lösen die national nicht
mehr gelöst werden können
umwelt teilen des sozialen arbeitsrecht
das finde ich wirtschaftspolitik zu
nehmen der euro das hat unheimliche
vorteile zufrieden und ich muss sagen
wenn es die nicht gäbe müsste man sie
wirklich erfinden
[Musik]
deshalb möchten beide dass die schweiz
auch teil davon wird
sie ist in deutschland und schweiz gibt
es ja so eine art hassliebe im grunde
wir bewundern die schweizer und fragen
uns wie ein so kleines land so gut
hinkriegt die schweiz ist eben nicht das
charmante alpenland das schwerpunktmäßig
von schwarzgeld lebt und der schweiz ich
einen sehr modernen industriestaat und
dieses wissen um diesen modernen
industriestaat mit einem hohen niveau
und innovationspotenzial und einem hohen
innovationswillen da es hat sich noch
nicht wirklich überall rumgesprochen und
also die positionen die sich schweiz
jetzt hatte und die stellung die sie hat
kann sie sich nur leisten weil es eine
eu um sie herum gibt und weiß nicht
stark genug sind trotz allem ich habe
auch verständnis wenn man die
europäische bürokratie nicht unbedingt
verinnerlichen möchte aber ich sage dann
auch immer bitte das was wir an
bürokratie haben aber im verhältnis zu
den erleichterung die ganzen dinge dass
wir gesetze vereinheitlicht haben und so
für die gerade für die firmen ist doch
ermöglicht haben für größere märkte zu
produzieren das sind dinge die man
vielleicht in der schweiz auch ein
bisschen mehr noch in die eine
waagschale werfen sollte ich glaube dass
diese masseneinwanderung initiative das
ist sehr viel angst macht und das ist
ihr beziehungen zwischen der eu und der
schweiz wirklich verbirgt
ich habe natürlich verständnis wenn man
in der schweiz bestimmte sorgen hat was
eine unangepasste zuwanderung etwa
betrifft natürlich habe ich dieses
verständnis ich mache mir diese sorgen
für deutschland auch wir werden es nicht
zulassen dass
dieser kontinent und kontrolliert durch
massenzuwanderung bestimmt also die lage
wird sich wieder normalisieren so und
dann wäre es für mich auch ein schönes
signal der schweiz oder wenigstens
innerhalb der europäischen union eine
gewisse zuwanderung dann auch zuließe
wegen mir mit kontingenten die man
definieren könnte weitere verhandlungen
zu dem thema sind absolut willkommen
mai 2014 beiden gelingt die wiederwahl
und ich bin froh dass wir wenn wir mal
die ganzen pro europäischen parteien
nehmen 90 prozent zustimmung haben für
die europäische idee
das ist ich finde auch ein ergebnis
werde der ard und wir haben die linken
die linken wollen ja auch senator aus
und so weiter die haben wir bei ihrem
kreis steinfurt bei etwa 8 prozent
gelassen
alles andere ist wo europäischen das
findet auch ein gutes ergebnis
also wir werden dann noch diejenigen die
jetzt an fd gewählt haben auf
bundesebene immerhin sieben prozent
die müssen mit ihrer teils berechtigten
kritik an und sozialmissbrauch und zwar
unbedingt die müssen wir auch wieder
einfangen
es müssen auch zum bestand
unsere politik machen dann werden beim
nächsten mal auch ein noch überzeugendes
ergebnis habe aber über freunde ich bin
fix und fertig ich habe jetzt 170
veranstaltungen hinter mir und jetzt
freue ich mich auf die 170 hier aber so
10 12 und trinken wollte ich werde mich
für eine sorgfältige verwendung der
europäischen gelder weiter einsetzen ist
ja mal ein spezialgebiet auch die
haushaltskontrolle dass wir da auch in
deutschland dann wirklich sagen können
okay guck mal die gelder die hier von
deutschland nach brüssel gehen
die werden auch vernünftigen
griechenland in anderen regionen
ausgegeben
brüssel der hauptsitz der eu kommission
der eu regierungen die kommission
verwaltet den großteil der gelder und
der haushaltskontrollausschuss des
parlaments kontrolliert ihre verwendung
in diesem ausschuss sitzen die beiden
wir kontrollieren als politiker in
diesem haushaltskontrollausschuss die
gesamtausgaben der europäischen union
sind diese gelder effizient eingesetzt
gibt es betrug gibt es korruption gibt
es eine unsachgemäße verwendung dieser
gelder all das wird bei uns kontrolliert
da haben kontrollausschuss überprüft
die ausgaben der gesamten eu eines eu
haushalts als ungefähr 160 milliarden
euro pro jahr inzwischen 160 milliarden
euro also ungefähr 180 milliarden
schweizer franken gesamtausgaben
das ist gleich viel wie die öffentliche
hand der schweiz eidgenossenschaft
kantone und gemeinden zusammen ohne
sozialleistungen ausgibt ein
vergleichsweise bescheidenes budget und
doch wollen ihre gräßler und markus
pieper ganz genau wissen was mit dem
geld geschieht
deshalb reist ihr gräßle mit dem
haushaltskontrollausschuss nach
griechenland sie ist nach den wahlen
sogar vorsitzende des ausschusses
sie will prüfen ob die eu-gelder hier
sachgerecht eingesetzt werden
das erste projekt die metro in
thessaloniki
hier läuft nichts mehr die bauarbeiten
sind seit dem jahr 2013 eingestellt
der offizielle eröffnungstermin wäre der
dezember 2014 gewesen
der griechische regierungsvertreter
spricht ausweichend von streit unter den
baufirmen
und ein weiterer grund für den baustopp
archäologische funde bei fast allen
geplanten metrostationen
bei der anschließenden sitzung stellt
sich heraus
die lage ist noch viel schlimmer als
gedacht
die metro ist riesig viele
unwägbarkeiten name vor und die metro
wird wohl auch gebaut werden die frage
ist nur mit welchem geld also etwas
interessanten aber der metro war dass
die lage schlechter ist als wir gedacht
haben
das heißt wenn sie tatsächlich eine
station kennen die besichtigt haben wenn
ihr sehr vorläufig nicht machen dann ist
das natürlich schon ein tiefschlag das
ganze projekt bei dieser station ganz
besonders wichtig ist die metro hat
sicherlich gebaut werden aber die frage
ist nur wo herr winter griechische staat
das geld es weiter zu bauen weil von der
eu kommt nichts mehr
und das ist eine offene frage stehen
jetzt auch nicht wirklich beantwortet
haben
dann inspiziert die delegation von inge
gräßle das trinkwasserreservoir carla
lag auch hier gibt es enorme verzögerung
der gouverneur gibt ebenfalls
archäologischen funden die schuld
[Musik]
wir sind etwas besorgt weil das projekt
laut unseren unterlagen gefährdet ist
der gouverneur schlägt einen besuch
direkt vor ort vor
die griechischen medien nimmt er gleich
mit denn er ist stolz auf den
projektstand
doch inge gräßle ist ernüchtert
und wenn das passiert wenn es nicht dann
hat die griechischen probleme weil sie
dann deutlich über 100 millionen
zurückzahlen muss wir haben man muss
sich permanent kümmern da muss man sich
auch unbeliebt machen und da darf man
auch nicht darum gehen dass man doch
bitte schön hier den beliebtheits preis
gewinnen will
die frage wie korrupt sind die
mitgliedsstaaten also ich bin mir sicher
dass die staats- und regierungschefs
über die frage noch nie diskutiert haben
weil da müsste man ja auf die einen und
die anderen zeigen und sagen leute ihr
müsst ihr jetzt endlich mal was
unternehmen
aber wir sehen mit kriegen land mit
italien oder mit rumänien und bulgarien
wir tun uns keinen gefallen wenn wir
hauptprobleme eines mitgliedslandes
nicht zum thema machen
aber die eu ebene hat dieses prinzip die
mitgliedstaaten sind zu stellen sie
müssen es mal so zu sagen so inhaliert
und dass sie gar nicht versteht dass die
schwächen der mitgliedstaaten auf die eu
ja ebenfalls gebaut ist unmittelbar auf
die eu zurückschlagen
ist das ein trinkwasserreservoir das
kann man nicht als trinkwasser benutzen
cloud
eine lösung ist für trinkwasser
reservoir nicht zu nutzen und befreite
defekt gewesen und das wäre eigentlich
das weg gewesen
wir haben jetzt mitgekriegt wir bauen
jetzt ein neues zuhause vor über 100
millionen euro für wassertiere und vögel
[Musik]
das nächste projekt besichtigung einer
autobahn
auch sie sollte längst fertig sein doch
davon kann keine rede sein
[Musik]
das projekt ist sie zu 60 63 prozent
fertig und da gibt es ja noch einiges zu
machen und 14 millionen euro vermindern
ende aber alles sind zuversichtlich dass
es bis nächstes jahr in die fertig ist
und dann ist es ja gut so
[Musik]
parallel zur autobahn entsteht ein
trassee für einen
hochgeschwindigkeitszug auch das trassee
sollte längst fertig sein
die mitgliedstaaten bestimmen wofür das
geld ausgegeben wird
sie sprechen zwar die programme mit der
kommission aber dann auch mit
unterschiedlichen kommission stylen und
so kommt es halt dass wir eine schiene
und eine straße parallel bauen mehr oder
weniger und wenn sie die frage jetzt
diskutieren mit denen mit den
unterschiedlichen kommission stylen dann
wird jeder auf science und sagt das
beißt sich überhaupt nicht das nimmt
sich auch gegenseitig nichts weg wir
werden sehen dass es natürlich genau so
wie ich auf jeden fall nimmt sich die
projekte gegen setzt das geld weg also
wenn die griechen sagen wir brauchen
diese autobahn sie brauchen diese
schiene
dann fließt leider auch europäisches
geld das ist eine achillesferse der
europäischen förderpolitik dass wir uns
zu sehr verlassen auf das was die
mitgliedstaaten als projekte für
vordringlich halten
ich fürchte dass wir konkurrenzprojekte
straße haben oder zur straße zu schieben
ich bin gespannt wie sich das alles
ökonomisch in dem land mit doch relativ
dünne besiedlung relativ wenig
bevölkerung verteilt an der verzögerung
seien geologische schwierigkeiten sagt
der griechische staat 20 jahre gedauert
und das ist alles natürlich mühsam
gewesen immer wieder die gleichen
probleme aber auch ihr team das
eigentlich fertig bauen will
nach abschluss der reise wie sieht ihre
bilanz aus
also es gibt nur erhebliche arbeit zu
machen erhebliche arbeit bei jedem diese
projekte und die wir dann auch gemacht
werden
die kommission muss jetzt die übersicht
geben über alle griechischen projekte
die wir 2007 bis 2013 finanziert haben
und was aus denen geworden ist ob sie
fertig sind oder nicht
und allein schon die übersicht zu
bekommen wird eine ziemliche wird ein
ziemlicher akt aber ich wollte auf jeden
fall daran da nicht locker lassen weil
allmählich muss sagen mir fällt schon
schwer immer wieder geduld mit
griechenland zu haben
[Musik]
auch markus pieper ist als
haushaltskontrolle unterwegs
[Musik]
deutsche fensterbauer beschweren sich
bei ihm dass ihre polnischen
konkurrenten ungerechtfertigt
subventionen von der eu erhalten würden
pieper will der sache nachgehen
europäischen idee es macht ja keinen
sinn die decke von unten nach oben zu
ziehen seitdem wie man das eben wenn ich
gewisse struktur der baustraßen halte
ich für sie lassen sich die botschaften
solar
[Musik]
aber mehr wissen hallo beschichtet ist
sich auf dem von piraten schon in der
mitarbeiter wochen will dann muss man
gibt doch dann müssen wir froh sein dass
man mit dem song passt bitte nehmen sie
mir dass sie mich an ihrer seite haben
auch mit den argumenten und wir haben
durchgesetzt
zum beispiel dass in der nächsten
förderperiode betriebe mehr als 1000
beschäftigten nicht mehr in die - im
regen antreten
das heißt wenn sie sagen das sind große
konzerne standen die fenster bauen lang
gab es eigentlich sein dass die noch
diese institution zu schützen wir unsere
frieden heißt das ganze und jetzt an
über scheint noch elf andere werben um
dann konkrete ergebnis zu haben
die kommission mit sehr offenen
verfahren dabei da hinterher zugeben was
kommt es nun ja das ist mein wahlkreis
wenn ich im wahlkreis von unternehmen
angesprochen werde pieper guck mal da in
polen wird subventioniert und wir
kriegen das geld nicht kümmert sich mal
darum dann ist es eine
selbstverständlichkeit dass man der
sache nachgeht wenden die polnischen
fenster betriebe tatsächlich
subventionen bekommen für ihre
produktion
das hieße dann ja auch
wettbewerbsverzerrung
auch inge gräßle besucht einen
unternehmer in ihrer region
auch er hat ein problem mit der eu die
eu kommission will die chemikalie krohn
sechs verbieten
die anwendung ist giftig das endprodukt
hingegen nicht doch der schutz der
arbeiter ist in der eu ohnehin schon
heute streng geregelt und ein
ersatzprodukt für chrome 6 gibt es nicht
gemacht dieses schöne glänzen dieses
spiegel reflektion kriegt man bisher mit
dem chrome 3 sachen leider nicht hin
also da das könnte man dem kunden
einfach dementsprechend so nicht mehr
anbieten für die automobilindustrie
natürlich dann die einstiegs leichte da
wäre dann natürlich auch nicht nur genau
so dekorativ zum einsetzen einfach würde
auch komplett wegfallen
auch automobilen bestehen würde dann
stark darunter leiden wir müssen
natürlich die teile dann teuer
exportieren behandeln lassen und dann
mit der teuer importieren
das ist die organisation des
produktionsstandort china würde ich mal
sagen das geht alles gar nicht wir
müssen über kommen 60 mal reden das geht
ja nicht das team das die
das sozusagen ganze verlagerungen von
produktions- und da hängt ja die ganze
automobilindustrie dranhängt
elektroindustrie dran
da hängt alles dran was blitzt und
glänzt dass wir dies ist dann außerhalb
der eu verlagern weil unsere
umweltvorschriften so streng sind das
bei uns nur noch das verbot übrig bleibt
dass die welt wird ja nicht dadurch
besser dass wir es nicht mehr tun aber
andere ist umso mehr tun und zwar mit
bedingungen die mit unseren nicht
annähernd vergleichbar sind
das kann es nicht sein
wochen später wie weit hat die
kommission markus pieper zu dem fenster
bauern informiert
unterm strich nicht sehr
zufriedenstellend hinhaltetaktik immer
mal wieder kleinere ergebnisse aber
nichts was uns jetzt wirklich in unserer
funktion als haushaltskontrolle
zufriedenstellen also ich muss da so ein
stück weit auch die kommission ist
wirklich kritisieren das ist
hinhaltetaktik
offensichtlich ja wenn es nichts zu
verbergen gibt dann hätte man uns diese
liste gleich geben können auf der
anderen seite immer zu sagen wir dürfen
hier nicht so kritisch nachfragen sonst
gefährden wir die europäische idee also
das kannst du jetzt auch nicht mehr sein
also wir haben da auf gut deutsch die
sprache zu fall ist denn jetzt dieses
dieses dieser zettel mit dem
implementierungs problem der falschen
hier
inge gräßle ist einen schritt weiter mit
chrome 6 sie will die eu chemikalien
agentur einladen die bei der kommission
für den verbots vollzug zuständig ist
die agenturen sind auch uns gegenüber
rechenschaftspflichtig wie sie
europäische gelder einsetzen und ich
werde natürlich den agenturchef hier
auch kommen lassen und ihn bitten uns
doch mal zu erklären wie die arbeit die
er macht im grunde vertretbar ist mit
dem europäischen steuerzahler denn
unsere arbeitnehmer zahlen steuern
unsere industrie stadt zahlt steuern und
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob diese
steuergelder dazu benutzt werden sollten
die existenz dieser firmen wirklich zu
gefährden durch eine bestimmte umsetzung
der europäischen gesetzgebung
[Musik]
nochmals wochen später ist markus pieper
weiter gekommen mit seinen abklärungen
zu den fensterbauer wir haben bislang
leider nur hinhalten antworten begonnen
wobei uns versprochen wurde das
rechtlich einwandfrei zu bewerten nun
endgültig im september für uns
abgeordnete nicht hinnehmbar sein dass
wir die fensterbauer in polen
subventionieren und die gleichzeitig
unseren fans aber an konkurrenz machen
inge gräßle hat inzwischen einen termin
mit der chemikalienagentur und der
kommission
[Musik]
hinter vorgehaltener hand räumt die
kommission ein dass das geplante verbot
von chrome 6 falsch ist es gibt keinen
ersatzstoff das endprodukt ist ungiftig
und der arbeitnehmerschutz ist sowieso
anderswo streng geregelt doch vor der
kamera mag das niemand zu sagen
die sitzung ist nicht öffentlich es gibt
eigentlich keine richtigen antworten es
gibt nach wie vor viele fragen alle
kollegen haben sich sehr kritisch zu
wort gemeldet sie haben dem rennt uns
auf den nägeln
über allen das sind noch hausaufgaben zu
machen
die probleme tauchen auf und wir sind
dabei sie sie anzugehen
ich glaube die frau gäste konnte doch
etwas zufrieden sein auch wenn die
zulassungsverfahren noch einiges zu
wünschen übrig lässt
viereinhalb seiten genauestens die
probleme um die europäische
chemikalienrecht linie die registrierung
von stoffen die frage des umgangs mit
gefährlichen substanzen sie warten wir
müssen jetzt auch genehmigt werden
aufgelistet
unser gruppenchef hat zu unterschreiben
wir haben es der kommission geschickt
dem kommissionspräsidenten viereinhalb
seiten und zurück kamen fünf zeilen
danke vom brief ich habe ihn gelesen
punkt und das muss ich sagen begreife
ich nicht das ist genau die eu die ich
nicht haben will
ich bin ich einen ernsthaften brief
schreibe möchte ich bitte auch gerne
eine ernsthafte antwort haben das war
aber keine ernsthafte antwort so
wiedersehen
auch markus pieper ist unzufrieden er
hat herausgefunden dass die klagen der
fensterbauer ungerechtfertigt sind von
tänzern da gibt es jetzt eine
information aktion die auch von den
verband der fensterbauer bestätigt ist
dass dieses geld nicht in die direkte
betriebliche produktion geflossen ist
sondern eher indirekt in unternehmen
durch werbe hilfen andere dinge zur
verfügung gestellt wurde auch nicht die
dimensionen die die fensterbauer so
beklagt haben sondern in viel geringerem
umfang
das ist nur eine sache die ist natürlich
ärgerlich für fensterbauer die in
deutschland oder anderen ländern
produzieren aber wenn das gemäss
europäischer regeln ist und wir nicht
auf dauer dort massenfertigung von
produkten unterstützen dann kann man das
so nicht verhindern
dann muss man das auch ein stück weit
akzeptieren sie haben gesagt geringere
dimensionen maus gedreht haben sich dann
da
kath
es handelt sich um einen tiefen
einstelligen millionenbetrag für die
ganze branche
viel aufwand für nichts
[Musik]
bei inge gräßle hingegen ist die chrome
6 frage nach wie vor offen
ich habe das gefühl dass die kommission
nach wie vor weit weg von den problemen
und in den handlungsdruck der betriebe
nicht sieht und deswegen muss man das
thema jetzt auch nochmals für den zum
thema machen im umweltausschuss gab es
eine diskussionsrunde und das ist
vielleicht was neues in der
umweltausschuss hat problematik
aufgegriffen und bemüht sich da auch um
lösungen
[Musik]
markus pieper auf dem weg ins parlament
trotz rückschlägen die bei den
fensterbauer kämpft er weiter für eine
sorgfältige mittelverwendung er will so
genannte vorbehalte gegenüber der
kommission durchsetzen
wir haben diese vor allem wegen
fehlerhafter land informationssysteme
also diese flächen messung zur geltung
gebracht
es sind politische vorbehalte die die
kommission nur dann auflösen kann denn
sie unsere bedingungen erfüllt also wir
wollen jetzt so schnell wie möglich auch
eine reaktion haben es geht schließlich
um geld irgendwo zwischen einer und 1
milliarden euro und dann muss die
kommission jetzt anfangen auch das geld
zurückzufordern
das bedeutet er will erstmals
durchsetzen dass die jährliche
kommissions- abrechnung nicht mehr
widerspruchslos genehmigt wird
anwesend sind nur wenige unter anderem
die unermüdliche inge gräßle ein so
wichtiger vorstoß und das parlament ist
leer
die arbeit wird der vorher im ausschuss
gemacht die arbeit wird von der fraktion
gemacht im parlament wird dann die
meinung der jeweiligen fraktionen
dargestellt so dass sich die
öffentlichkeit ein bild machen kann und
bei den abstimmungen also wenn es dann
wirklich ernst wird da sind wir ja auch
zu 100% dann da und werden unserer
verantwortung dann auch gerecht
vielen dank herr präsident meine damen
und herren das entlassungsverfahren ist
kompliziert schwierig manchmal sehr
politisch deshalb zu beginn der dank an
alle kollegen schatten berichterstatter
und ihre teams für die geduldige
zusammenarbeit
meine damen und herren genug ist genug
die prüfverfahren einiger länder haben
strukturelle mängel und das seit vielen
jahren
das bringt unser system der geteilten
mittelverwendung in misskredit und meine
damen und herren das sage ich als
befürworter der europäischen
gemeinschaft ich finde wir müssen unsere
schwachstellen selbst beheben und die
kritik nicht den europa gegnern
überlassen vielen dank
[Applaus]
am abend markus pieper und inge gräßle
rechnen mit ihren parlamentskollegen
nach werden sie am nächsten tag die eu
regierung die kommission zwingen können
die missbräuchlich ausgezahlten
subventionen zurückzuverlangen werden
die eu-mitgliedstaaten endlich die
fehlerhaften landvermessung systeme
korrigieren müssen
am nächsten tag die 751 eu
parlamentarier werden gleich über
piepers vorschlag abstimmen
[Musik]
bitte beten auf vorschlag des a4 bei
änderungsantrag bei paragraf 283
ermöglichen änderungsantrag haben und
ich hoffe sie können dann zustimmen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danach eilte sofort zu seiner
pressekonferenz
[Musik]
das ist ja von uns als vorschlag man
wirklich gekommen um auch mal neun neue
ideen zu bringen um mehr druck auf dem
kessel zu bringen wir haben 95 prozent
der diskussion in unserem ausschuss hat
sich nur um dieses wort vor wald gedreht
das zeigt mir dass der ganze bericht im
grunde nicht mehr so viel wert ist dass
wir seit jahren hier eine routine
produzieren auf die kaum noch jemand so
richtig rücksicht nimmt und jetzt mit
einer gelben karte
es ist eine neue idee da kann man auch
in sachen wer jährige finanzperiode mal
etwas anders aus strategischer sicht des
parlaments rangehen wenn etwas ein
technisches europäisches thema
entschieden wird sowie die
haushaltskontrolle
da finden sie keine große europäische
begeisterung sie werden die journalisten
für ein solches thema leider nicht
hinter dem ofen hervorlocken können um
dann da großartig darüber zu berichten
[Musik]
einmal im monat stehen vor den büros der
parlamentarier solche kisten
es sind die umzugskisten für den zweiten
parlamentssitz für straßburg
die deutsch französische aussöhnung hat
eben auch ihren preis und der preis
heißt straßburg und heißt die
beibehaltung des sitzes in straßburg ich
als hohen denkbar dass deutschland sich
gegen einen parlamentssitz in straßburg
wendet einfach hause aus rücksicht auf
die deutsch französischen beziehungen
[Musik]
es gibt die beiden parlamente wissen sie
wenn das am meisten ärgert uns als
abgeordnete
wir müssen dann auch diese lasten auf
uns nehmen und dann mal nach straßburg
nach mal nach brüssel das macht uns auch
kein spaß wir fordern aber auch jedes
jahr dass wir nur einen standort haben
wollen wir wollen das auflösen
aber dann haben wir die grundlagen
verträge die kann man nur einstimmig
ändern das wollen alle so und wenn wir
straßburg auflösen wollen dann wird
frankreich dagegen stimmen das parlament
in straßburg inge gräßle bereitet sie
hier auf neue abstimmungen vor
stierkämpfe also für die zucht von
stören vor allem in spanien
dann haben wir schon viele mails
bekommen und ich habe auch schon bevor
die erste mail kam im haushaltsausschuss
gegen eu mittel für jungstiere gestimmt
die zur stierkampf zwecken gezüchtet
werden
und dann will ich heute auch dagegen
stimmen und ist auch mir auf keinen fall
durch die lappen gehen also das dass wir
uns richtig verstehen das steht in der
verordnung drin dass es zulässig ist das
ist das problem
das heißt sie hätten sich allemal wir
jetzt menschen hätten alle mal schafft
ein bisschen vorher aufwachen müssen
ich habe nämlich mal in einer waage
arbeitet ganz früher diese abstimmung
haben wir verloren
wir waren in der minderheit und deswegen
gibt es auch dieses jahr wieder
stierkampf geltung und nächstes jahr
kommen dieser antrag wieder und dann
werde ich wieder dagegen stimmen weil
ich nicht einsehe dass wir kurz und gut
ich halte so tierquälerei ehrlich das
war so was auch nur mit eu-geldern
fordern soll
das ist aber immer der wunsch der
spanischen kollegen
der kampf von inge gräßle geht weiter
sie zitiert kommissionsmitglieder in
ihren haushaltskontrollausschuss und übt
scharfe kritik
ich habe nicht den eindruck dass die
kommission mit allzu großem eifer
geprüft hat wir haben das ja einen
umfangreichen fragebogen erhoben und
kann nur sagen dass die kommission
bestimmte verträge von einem team
überhaupt nicht geprüft hat also wie
können sie sagen dass ihr alles in
ordnung ist wenn sie die verträge gar
nicht geprüft haben die
implementierungsleistungen gar nicht
geprüft haben und nicht davon aus dass
sie sich mit solchen kleinkram
beschäftigung aber wir halten
kommissar sie können gerne auch
antworten aber ich möchte schon wissen
wie das jetzt weitergeht
und sie sollten wissen dass wir das auf
keinen fall nachgeben also ich auf jeden
fall nicht aber ich muss schon sagen
dass die art der dass die art der mittel
die implementierung die generaldirektion
management hier uns gezeigt hat dass sie
schon in hohem maße in hohem maße
muslimas das war es waren über zahlungen
die nie hätte stattfinden dürfen
und die man jetzt also rigoros nennt das
halte ich also für eine für eine derart
kreative auslegung des haushaltsrechts
dass ich echt da nicht mitgekommen wenn
ich habe es lange nicht begriffen
und da ich dann begriffen haben muss ich
sagen finde ich finde es mir gut ich
freue mich dass es geändert haben
ich muss ihnen sagen werden auch gar
nichts anderes übrig geblieben als es zu
ändern
also hat das schicksal man wieder nicht
gut mit mir gemeint weil die brötchen
ausverkauft waren was bis jetzt
eigentlich ganz selten vorgekommen nicht
und da musste ich mir selbst
einschmieren
ich habe aber noch zwei käse regel zwar
mentaler erbeutet uns ein viel zu
trockenes brötchen aber bei der abwägung
gar nichts oder das hat das gewonnen
jeden montag fehlt sie von ihrem
wohnsitz in süddeutschland nach brüssel
oder straßburg zum parlament das heißt
stundenlanges autofahrer wenn ich dann
ankommen nach ein paar stunden bin ich
mit dem was war fertig da habe ich
darüber nachgedacht habe mich dann auch
aus geärgert ja ich bin dann am amt auch
am ende mit dem ärgern und am ende mit
dem sich beschäftigen habe dann alle
offenen fragen aufgeklärt haben plan für
die probleme wie man sie lösen könnte
autofahren ist für mich fast
unerlässlich um die arbeit überhaupt zu
bewältigen
heute ist der entscheidende moment
sie will ihre kommissions- kritik im
parlament präsentieren
das war schon wichtig zu wissen ich will
morgen schon gewinnen kann sich jetzt
schon sagen in dieser frage wo ich
einfach die dinge seit elf jahren
beobachte und feststellung getroffen
habe für die wahnsinnig ungern verlieren
und das schlimme ist dass man jetzt
nicht derart viel unseren wird weil in
diesem parlament punkt ja keiner mehr
auf die fakten das machen ja alles nur
den mund auf und das muss ich schon
sagen diese ganzen anti europäer die
reden einen scheiß daher ohne bar jeder
fakten kenntnis fakten zählt gar nichts
mehr rechts kontakt egal war super
[Musik]
frau präsidentin frau vizepräsidentin
der rechnungshof weise der us präsident
hat sich willkommen wir freuen uns dass
wir hier sind und wissen es sehr zu
schätzen im mittelpunkt meines
entschließungsantrags und der des
haushaltskontrollausschuss steht die
geteilte mittel verwaltung und die
schwächen in den verwaltungssystemen der
mitgliedsstaaten die seit vielen jahren
bestehen
ich möchte darum bitten dass auch morgen
im plenum zu tun weil diese anträge dem
text verwässern und damit den einfluss
des europäischen parlaments und der
kommission im rat schwächen sagen dass
wir wussten ist scheiße weil ich das
jetzt ob das ist unser koordinator heute
nicht da ich das ist doch scheiße
petra ist nicht darauf versteht das ist
dass ich kann nur sagen sprinten dauern
bitte bringt
am nächsten tag jetzt entscheiden die eu
parlamentarier über inge gräßle antrag
sie will die mitgliedstaaten zwingen die
verwendung von eu-geldern besser zu
überwachen
ist zur letzten sekunde versucht sie
abgeordnete zu überzeugen
der zeuge die kompakten der computer die
nacht
[Applaus]
ich habe wirklich alles gewonnen ich hab
nichts verloren obwohl einfach nicht
alles was mir wichtig war habe ich
gewonnen
das werde ich bin ich schon sagen also 3
mario ist ein medium wie hätte in dem
fall auf diese charge gebaut
wir haben sehr große unterstützung
erfahren von dem bericht und dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar
unsere mitgliedstaaten die vor ort
verantwortlich sind für die geldausgabe
sie haben ein sehr eigenwilliges
berichtssystem und die verifikation der
zahlen die die häuser 2013 großem umfang
erfolgt die zeigt dass wir uns
eigentlich nicht auf die mitgliedstaaten
verlassen können
der bericht umfasst einige neuigkeiten
und zwar hat sich das haus voll hinter
die bisherigen vorbehalt gestellt die
die kommission selbst gemacht was das
finanzmanagement vor allem schert
managementbereich anbetrifft ich mache
das jetzt seit elf jahren seit ich im
parlament bin das ist so wie mit polizei
wenn es sie man weiß nicht so genau was
sie bewirkt aber wenn es sie nicht gäbe
wäre es wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer
also wir zwingen behörden zur
rechenschaft
sowohl in den mitgliedsstaaten als auch
auf eu ebene
auch markus pieper als kritischer
vorstoß zeit erfolg die
agrarsubventionen werden besser
kontrolliert französischen agrargelder
da hat es eine erste rückzahlung vor
jahren bereits gegeben 1,1 milliarden
euro weil die französischen landnutzung
systeme nicht funktioniert haben und die
nächste tranche also es ist schon wieder
von einer milliarde euro die rede
die frankreich zusätzlich wird
zurückzahlen müssen und wenn man das mal
in der summe sieht 2 milliarden euro
zurück in den europäischen haushalt
wegen fehlerhafter verwendung dann
spricht das doch schon für die macht die
wir als haushalts kontrolleure auch
haben hier die eu wird nie perfekt sein
aber abgeordnete wie markus pieper und
inge gräßle arbeiten daran sie täglich
zu verbessern
[Musik]
mit dem neuen toyota rav4 firma 4 und
hybrid die ideale kombination für die
schweiz